so what I'm going to now do is I'm going
to show you our two proofs for this
because each proof I like I love
problems which have multiple proofs and
each proof kind of highlights the
strengths of a couple of different
approaches and uh I I want you to just
have a think before you look at these
two different methods how would you go
about proving this right how would you
try and reverse this logic not having
any assumptions about the particular
shape that you've got and prove that the
the right angle here use that as your
starting point rather than your ending
point it leads to the knowledge you can
prove that A B has to be a diameter have
a think about it before you keep
watching
all right so here's what I'm going to do
I'm going to go with this circle
and what I'm going to do is I'm going to
call this proof one
and we'll call it plain geometry because
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
have my best effort at quite literally
reversing the logic that we employed
before it's not going to be identical
because I'm proving something different
but I am going to use much the same kind
of ideas it will take a slightly bit
longer bit but not a whole lot okay
all right so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to say look suppose I should get
that right on that line there that's
more helpful okay suppose I'm going to
not start from a diameter I'm going to
have the center of the circle and then
I've got some angle somewhere that I
know is 90 degrees so at some angle
somewhere on the circle so suppose we
place it oh I don't know somewhere like
here
now for reasons they're going to become
obvious in a moment I'm not actually
going to I'm going to create something
that doesn't look like the diameter
because
I don't want to rely on the fact that my
diagram looks like it must be the case I
want to actually use logic and deduction
right so you can see what I've got here
it's not actually an 80 degree angle
that looks obtuse to me but what I can
do is I can still use the logic that I
normally would and not rely on my eyes
fooling me so I'm just going to say yes
I have at this point P from an A and A B
I've got this right angle and now what I
want to prove is that a b is a diameter
now no it doesn't look like it
especially when I connect it up to the
center as you're going to see you're
like how does it look like a diameter at
all but again that's kind of my point
all right so
how can I say that a b is a damage how
can I prove it well like I mentioned
before I'm going to use some of the same
uh logical deductive moves that I used
earlier but I have to use them running
in a different direction okay so I'm
going to start with a very similar
construction I'm going to from the
center
I'm going to join up this uh interval
here op and it does the same thing that
I had before because I've got this
Center here and I've got one two three
points that I know are all on the
circumference okay so what I've got here
is these lengths here have to be equal
because they're all radio all right
so so far so good then what I can say is
I've got uh the angles that I had before
which were from those isosceles
triangles right even though I don't know
what they're equal to I still know that
they're equal to each other so again
sort of rehearsing this logic I think I
said I had let's call this Alpha
and this Alpha over here so again you
can see I'm using triangle a o p it's
isosceles there and I'm going to do the
same what colors did I use purple right
I'm going to use the same logic over
here so I've got beta and beta here so
maybe to make it a little more obvious
what I'll do is I'll highlight this is
my isosceles triangle here on the left
and then I also have
another one a corresponding one over
here
okay
so I've got my isosceles triangles and I
think you're probably content to know
the alphas and the betas that are equal
to each other
now at this point remember what I'm
trying to prove is that a b is a
diameter I don't even know that a b is
actually a straight line at this point
and so what I want to do is set out to
prove that actually a through o through
b that these are co-linear but they're
not sort of offered a funny angle like
this because I I don't know that there's
one chord that unites them at this point
all I know is that a p b is 90 degrees
okay so given that I don't know that aob
a and O and B are collinear
um they they have separate angles
associated with them so I don't know
what those are equal to so let's call
this one Theta that goes uh from the
middle over to a and then let's call
this one Phi so again from the middle
over to OB
all right now similar kind of logic what
I can say is this bigger shape here are
a o b p this pair of triangles combines
to make a quadrilateral so what I can
say is in uh quadrilateral
what did I call it a o b p I'm going to
consider those uh those four angles I
guess that make up the quadrilateral
right so I start with uh Alpha which is
over here on this left hand side then
I've got this angle in here so it's
theta plus Phi
then I've got this uh beta over on the
right hand side
plus this other pair of adjacent angles
that combines to make angle a p b so you
can see that's an alpha plus beta
now because this is a quadrilateral the
angle sum is not 180 degrees like I was
looking at before the angle sum is 360
because
that's a fairly basic property of
quadrilaterals I mean it's made up of
two triangles Each of which is 180
that's where we prove that from okay so
now what I can do is just just a little
bit of rearrangement right if I put this
theta plus Phi over to the left hand
side and then if you have a look at what
you have remaining
um there's the two Alphas that I made
before and there's the two beaters in
there respective triangles so they're
going to be double
Alpha plus beta
and that's equal to 360. and now I can
use the fact that because Alpha plus
beta being 90 degrees is my starting
point not my ending point I can bring
that in I can substitute that in for
this Alpha plus beta that I can see here
right so this is going to be theta plus
Phi
equal plus rather 2 times 90. so that's
180 degrees equals
360. so my reason for that is that Alpha
Beta is equal to 90 and then you can see
what I've got here is just Alpha sorry
theta plus Phi doing the subtraction
that's 180 degrees which means that aob
is actually a straight angle because
that's what 180 degrees is defined as
right so aob is a straight line or a
straight angle either of them are
equivalent I think in this context
okay now it's a straight line now all
I've proven at the moment is that a b is
a chord of the circle because uh it
joins two points on the circumference
and it's it's a straight line right but
I haven't proved it it's the diameter
what's the special property that the
diameter has
um and that is the fact that it's the
unique chord that is the longest chord
you can make which is two radii and to
end and you can see here AO and OB
they're both radii right so I will say
but
um a B I can call it one line now or one
interval because I just proved that it's
straight A B is equal to uh a o plus o b
which equals 2R therefore
it has to be a diameter because that's
the only kind of chord that is that long
all right happy times I am finished that
was proof number one playing geometry I
used uh very similar kinds of properties
the angle sums of
um of some uh polygons here in this case
a quadrilateral rather than a triangle
though that's built off triangles anyway
I used this fact here which was my
starting point rather than my ending
point and then I can end with the fact
that it's a diameter great